and uh how do you make money
in all of this so we um we have two
models we take a
we either have a a monthly subscription
fee that providers pay us
or we take a percentage of tuition um so
we have we have two different models
right now
and i'm looking at the most expensive
one and uh five days a week eight to
five
full time is 3300 doesn't seem that bad
um they're it all is pretty affordable
um and then how do the providers feel
about your service and
paying you some monthly fee oh
you mean i'm the i'm the founder of the
company so i'm gonna tell you they love
it but
well i'm just curious like it's is it
that
do people pay through the platform as
well is that how like our parents pay so
yeah when the parent enrolls into the
program they pay through the plan
so just like airbnb you pay you take a
percentage of that or
yes yes so for some for some programs we
take a percentage
whether that's 5 10 or something 10 10
so to be on the platform any new
customers they get
they pay you 10 but they're existing
customers they don't have to pay you on
that's right when they bring
students onto the platform they don't
pay us that's right so and the average
school
is going to be average school has a
thousand a year
uh yeah it has about eight to ten
children in the program
and yeah about ten thousand dollars a
year that's exactly right yeah so it's a
no-brainer
to acquire one of those students for a
thousand dollars for that yeah
yeah exactly right uh because they run
at a 30 margin or something
so this is how they basically get new
customers in the door
well i mean it's amazing and then you
are
slowly going into micro schools and how
is that going
so it's going really well um and uh you
know we made an announcement that we
were
expanding into micro schools and yeah
since we've made that announcement
you know we've been getting a lot of
interest um which has been great
and uh and uh we we launched it
nationally as well
and so that's been really exciting so
we've been getting folks from all over
the country
who are starting micro schools um
another thing we're seeing a big trend
of right now is outdoor schools
um so folks are starting outdoor
programs um
um to to deal with covid um and so
that's going
i think that's yeah i mean if you just
look at the
chances of getting it outdoors and
socially distance and with mass
man it really is much lower according to
total science today
if you're doing this stuff outdoors in
some places you can be outdoors for the
entire year or most of it
yeah exactly you know the bay area if
you have a sweater and a tent and
maybe a heat lamp you're fine for the
entire year there's probably
only a couple of days in the peninsula
where it's 50 or 60 degrees and even
then you could wear a sweater and be
okay
um yeah i mean yeah go for it
not good the idea of outdoor schools
came from scandinavia
and so and so and you know they operate
with the idea that there's no bad
weather there's just bad clothes
um so you know i heard that i thought
that was a german expression
but so you cannot and so um so the bay
area
you know you can totally do year round
uh but in places like new york we even
have four schools in new york but
they tend to not be open during the
coldest um winter months
did you say forest schools yeah we call
them forest schools
outdoor schools nature yeah danish has
forest schools yeah
and kids in nature i mean adults in
nature do really well and
why not have the entire school outdoors
yeah it's great kids and
i think one of the great things about
these micro schools is i was talking to
a parent who
you know their kid is adhd or you know
just high energy what
you know depending on how you feel about
that diagnosis
if it's real or not or if it's over
diagnosed
and they were i think
uh you know faced with this teachers
pressuring them to put their kids on
adhd medicine so they would sit and
shut up basically and stay focused as
opposed to being vibrant young kids who
want to run around
and i just think that's another
opportunity here is
you know as a parent i i don't
understand why so many people are so
quick to drug their kids and put them on
this medication to keep them as factory
farming
schools and you know maybe it would be
better to have them
have the ability to be out and about be
much totally
yeah totally i agree i agree completely